happy Cyber Monday yeah yeah that's
right
today is Cyber Monday when everyone is
on their computers or as Andy calls it
porn at work day
you gotta get by that firewall he does a
very good job yeah what's going on Joe
Biden in the news this weekend Joe Biden
debuted his new campaign slogan you know
what it is this is real
no malarkey no malarkey that's his
campaign slogan no malarkey narrowly
beat out no bunk no poppycock and no
tomfoolery
that's insane those are all the anti
shenanigans candidate yeah I know
yeah when Bernie Sanders heard the
slogan he said you kids today in your
hip lingo malarkey I listen so that's a
word from like 1902 it I didn't I don't
get it
no more markets and is that really the
problem yeah - much malarkey yeah yeah
well Millennials are gonna flock to that
campaign gotta mention this is a crazy
story in New Jersey someone found a
message in a bottle from 1907 yeah the
note said the Jets suck
in beautiful penmanship of Emerson yeah
and then it said no malarkey